meine hier nicht logisch dass er so
eines wie slomka vor allem im hochsprung
wo wir eigentlich alle ressourcen als
für den acer gewährt in ganz afrika show
nicht normal dass sie ihre milliarden us
agent und liegt ein internationales vor
einer woche berichteten wir an dieser
stelle über krieg und armut im kongo
über die folgen davon und über einen
schweizer trotz bomben beschuss und
plünderungen mit seiner familie haushalt
carlos und christin schule mit ihren
kindern david und sarah kämpften
jahrelang dafür dass die hoffnung im
kongo nicht abhanden kommt im
nationalpark musiker rettete carlos die
gorillas vor der ausrottung
dieses engagement machte ihn weltberühmt
das war vor zwölf jahren was ist aus ihm
in der zwischenzeit gewohnten ich treffe
carlos an einem überraschenden ort in
der ökologie
[Musik]
carlos singt ab und zu in der angeblich
besten pizzeria bukavu diese gehört
zufälligerweise ihm selber und war lange
zeit auch die einzige pizzeria weit und
breit aus dem naturschützer ist ein wirt
und hotelier geworden
er baute sein haus zu einem hotel und
restaurant und um nachdem er für die
gorillas alles getan hat was er tun
konnte
vor 20 jahren haben eine etage auf das
ausgebaut
dezember hier war ein kindergarten
meine kinder haben hier geleitet in zehn
jahren und habe diese im garten gefällt
und hier das restaurant gebaut
nächtelang sitzt er an seinem computer
mit fotos videos und texten hatte die
geschichte des kongos und sein leben
dokumentiert was will er damit erreichen
wir können manchmal sehr schwierig dass
ich so kompliziert aber für mich sehr
wichtig dass die geschichte irgendwo
geschrieben ist dass das nicht einfach
totale vergangenheit ich werde so viel
immer so klappt so viele schlimme
situationen erlaubt im in afrika tour
mit ihr vergessen da gibt es keine
nachforschungen und bereiten die dabei
dass wenigstens liebe und ich finde das
sehr wichtig das sind dass sie den chef
der alten bleibt
[Musik]
nach schätzungen von internationalen
organisationen sollen im kongo von 1994
bis heute rund fünf millionen menschen
ums leben gekommen sein
verschiedenste gruppierungen bekämpfen
sich viel zu viele waffen in diesem
krieg bei dem oft unklar ist wer für was
und gegen wen kämpft und bei dem immer
nur eines klar ist es geht um rohstoffe
kahlos bilder zeigen die jahrzehnte die
aus dem kongo einen jener hoffnungslosen
fälle auf der liste der gescheiterten
staaten gemacht haben
womit hier ausgewandert sind als land ja
nur einigen wasser funktioniert und dann
ist der genozid holen wir wandern dann
haben wir zwei jahre lang oder her
flüchtlinge und dennis tretow und
familien auf berge und ich frage dich
oder mehreren dank des gut zwei wochen
durch eine million zurück und nach dem
mit einer zweite die buchung mir dank
den zehn jahre wurde und es ist
natürlich schwierig daher wachse und
alles verachtet für die park und im
allgemeinen die ganze bevölkerung
[Musik]
werden jahren kämpfte sich carlos bei
seinen fahrten in den park über die
schlechtesten straßen die man sich
denken kann
die miserablen verkehrsverbindungen sind
wohl das größte entwicklungshemmnis des
landes carlos furchtlos durch diese
gefährliche gegend sein geheimnis er
redete mit allen und alle kannten ihn
etwas mulmig wurde ihm nur wenn deutsch
milizen der mai mai auftauchten oder die
verbreiteten kindersoldaten
ich bin also um auf- oder gefasst wurde
und muss sagen da nicht so 15
lindow mit humor kam mit kalaschnikow
und das ist einer von deiner moment sie
wollen vermeiden angekommen
total unberechenbar
ich erinnere da damals die sich hinter
david und zahlreichen autocar mit der
kinderstimme und die winterstimmung hat
mit einem meter zu
zudem braucht mit kalaschnikows kritik
sie sind das hieße aber und das ist
wirklich moment so wurden wir sagen
nicht zu kurz kommen
[Musik]
die kinder der schule es wuchsen die
meiste zeit im kongo auf zwei mal
mussten sie flüchten 1998 in die schweiz
und zwei jahre vorher nach belgien nur
carlos blieb um das haus der familie und
das naturschutzprojekt im park zu retten
die kinder vermissen den vater und
hatten angst um ihn
[Musik]
heute leben sarah und david in brüssel
david studiert betriebswirtschaft wo
will später auch noch pilot werden
sarah studiert marketing woran erinnern
sie sich mit dem krieg haben wir viele
unserer freunde verloren weil sie
irgendwo verschwanden
es gab damals keine sozialen netzwerk
gewollt so war das am anfang schwierig
als die freunde von einem tag auf den
anderen nicht mehr da waren
man fragte sich als kind wo sind sie nur
die freunde haben sie den krieg um
gespürt ich habe beim ersten mal nichts
begriffen
ich war noch zu klein ich sah nur wie
man und papa in panik gerieten erst
später als die familie auf der flucht
getrennt war habe ich begriffen wie
ernst es ist das war der schlimmste
moment ich denke die trennung als wir
weg gingen und vom vater getrennt worden
haben sie da angst um ihren vater gehabt
ja genau so gewaltsam getrennt zu sein
das war schwierig wir haben ihnen ihre
eltern erklärt was da passiert sie
benutzten immer ganz einfach geworden
wir sollten keine panik das wäre alles
vorbei gehen sie haben uns nie gesagt es
ist eine brutale trennung geben könnte
und dass es sich um einen krieg handele
sie blieben ganz sanft um nicht panik
auszulösen
verstehen sie denn heute warum es diesen
krieg überhaupt gibt
das land ist reich und alle wollen davon
profitieren
das schicksal des kongo ist in einem
gewissen sinne verdammt durch seinen
reichtum ist reich seine rohstoffe sind
unbegrenzt
man hat auch in anderen ländern afrikas
gesehen was das auslöst
es gibt immer dieses politische spielen
leute die ins land kommen und ihre
eigenen interessen vertreten
[Musik]
das nächste kapitel dieser geschichte
führt uns wieder zurück in den kongo in
einem außenbezirk der stadt poker gut
gut gesichert befindet sich hier die
zitty oft scheu die stadt der freude
hier leben 90 frauen die dem zum opfer
fielen was man hier sexuellen
terrorismus nennt hier hat kristian
schuller ein neues engagement gefunden
sie ist direktorin dieser stadt der
freude wenn sie wie hier ihre
therapeutin und trifft dann sammlung
sich oftmals die schrägsten geschichten
an den vergewaltigung ist im kongo so
etwas wie eine waffe im krieg es öffnet
sich ein panorama des schreckens das
sich aus vielen einzelnen schicksalen
zusammensetzt
für alle die hier arbeiten hat sich das
leben grundsätzlich verändert sogar bei
jenen die sich zum beispiel um die
gärten kümmern hat sich vieles
relativiert bei dem was die leute als
problem empfinden die alltäglichen
sorgen sind ohne jede bedeutung im
angesicht des schrecklichen dass wir
hier erfahren wenn sie es mit frauen zu
tun haben deren geschlechtsorgane
zerstört sind die nichts mehr haben die
von der familie verstoßen worden
die so etwas wie mutterschaft nie kennen
werden dann sehen sie das leben
vollkommen anders
die stadt der freude besteht aus einem
bungalow dorf das platz für 90 frauen
bietet christin zeigt mir die anlage die
in der chaotischen stadt bukavu wirkt
wie eine oase der ordentlichkeit
christian schertz mitsangen und es
herrscht eine atmosphäre die sind
schrecken vergessen lässt denn diese
frauen erlebt raten
ich sage immer das ist der ort wo ich am
meisten gelacht haben viele leute denken
hier gebe es nur blut und tränen
aber als wir mit dem aufbau dieser
institution begonnen
da haben die betroffenen frauen selber
diesen namen
statt der freude gewählt wir wollten das
nicht aber schlussendlich war es ihr
projekt und heute verstehe ich es der
name passt eben darum weil wir hier so
viel und so viel freude haben ist es
auch eine stadt der tränen
ja es gibt tränen vor allem am anfang
aber wie gesagt wir wollen dieses leid
in kraft verwandeln und diese tränen der
schmerzen tränen der freude
jan ist 24 jahre alt und ihr leben war
eine folge von schrecken und elend bis
sie hierher kam
ich habe sie vor längerer zeit
kennengelernt im spital von bann ziehen
sie war schwanger und sie wollte dieses
kind nicht sie hat sich gegen eine mauer
geworfen und wollte so dieses kind
hätten
davon konnten wir sie abhalten
dann arbeitet heute in der küche der
city offshore i so bleibt sie in kontakt
mit kristin die ihr wie sie sagt das
leben gerettet habe es gebe keinen tag
an dem sie nicht daran denke was ihr
passiert sei sagt schon damals vor acht
jahren aus die soldaten sie entführt
hatten
und so erzählt sie ihre geschichte
ich war noch ein mädchen gerade 14 jahre
alt
es war um 19 uhr und wer schliefen schon
fast da kamen einige soldaten der
hutu-miliz inter haben wir in unser haus
sie begannen uns zu belästigen
wir waren zu zweit und sie hatten schon
15 mädchen aus dem nachbardorf dabei sie
haben uns alle in den wald mitgenommen
unterwegs töteten sie zwölf der 17
mädchen darunter meine schwester als wir
dann in ihrem camp ankamen tief im wald
als mich einer der kommandanten
vergewaltigt danach hat er mir den lauf
seines gewehrs in die vagina gesteckt
zwei monate später merkte ich dass ich
schwanger war
sohn gebar einen sohn von dem sie nicht
sagen kann welche ihre vielen
vergewaltiger der vater ist was ich von
diesem kind ja mein herz war gespalten
ein teil wollte dass es stirbt ein
anderer teil wollte es behalten
doch schließlich hatte ich alle hoffnung
verloren und wollte mich in einen fluss
stürzen
dann kam in die city of joy und dort
lernte sie christin kennen sie lehrte in
vielen therapiestunden sich mit ihrem
schicksal auseinander zu setzen und
langsam haben sie dann begonnen auch
hier kind etwas geld zu haben
[Musik]
die stadt der freude ist gegen aussen
gut gesichert weil man sich hier nicht
scheut die verbrechen beim namen zu
nennen
fürchtet man die rache der täter ist die
mutterorganisation der city of joy
sie wurde von der amerikanischen
schriftstellerin fenster gegründet deren
theaterstück macchina monolog sie
berühmt gemacht hatte der aufenthalt in
der stadt der freude soll den frauen
helfen über ihre verletzungen hinweg zu
kommen in dem sie reden und reden reden
über das was ihnen passiert ist ein
aufenthalt für eine begrenzte zeit der
ihr zerstört das selbstbewusstsein
wieder herstellen soll
sie sollen hier lernen draußen in der
gesellschaft eine aktive rolle zu
spielen
die frauen sollen in ihre dörfer
zurückkehren
manche bleiben für ihre ausbildung noch
etwas länger hier doch wir wollen keine
städterinnen aus ihnen machen
nein sie sollen zurückgehen aufs land
und das was sie hier gelernt haben an
ihrer mütter und schwestern weitergehen
wenn man sieht mit wie viel kraft viele
von ihnen hinaus in die welt gehen
dann bin ich wirklich sehr stolz
die stadt der freude wird durch spenden
vor allem aus den usa finanziert sie ist
teil einer weltweiten bewegung gegen die
sexuelle ausbeutung
viele der fälle von dem hier höre sie
könnten direkt aus dem lehrbuch des
unmenschen stammen
es gibt so viele fälle hier die mich
schockiert haben aber man kann keinen
gewaltakt mit dem anderen vergleichen
aber wenn sie zum beispiel eine junge
mutter treffen die ihnen erzählt wie sie
mit ihren kindern entführt wurde und
hören dass mutter und kinder
vergewaltigt worden sind in aller
öffentlichkeit und wie es dann in einem
anfall der verrücktheit den
vergewaltiger nicht reichte die frauen
zu zerstören und ihre häuser
niederzubrennen
nein dass sie auch noch zwangen ihre
toten kinder auf zu essen
das ist unglaublich was ist denn der
grund für diese grausamkeit
ich weiß gar nicht ob man sich das
vorstellen kann was es heißt dass
menschen die man physisch und psychisch
zerstört hat zusätzlich noch in den
kannibalismus zu stoßen
ich frage mich dann oft gibt es menschen
die uns glauben wenn wir diesen horror
beschreiben ohne grund ist ein horror
der hier passiert dem konto
weit weg von den kameras der
weltöffentlichkeit weit weg von den
aktualitäten der welt
[Musik]
etwas außerhalb der stadt unterstützt
wieder eine große farm llc dass carlos
und christin teilweise gemeinsam
betreiben
die farm ist 300 hektaren gross gewährt
reis mais und gemüse angepflanzt
es arbeiten 100 leute aus der umgebung
und 13 jener vergewaltigten frauen für
die eine rückkehr in ihre dörfer nicht
mehr möglich war
[Musik]
dank dieser farm versorgt sich die city
of joy teilweise selber mit
lebensmitteln
hier werden auch fische gezüchtet oder
ziegen gehalten
ein projekt auf das christin stolz ist
weil es modellcharakter haben
stellen sie sich vor wenn es mir solche
projekte gäbe dann könnte der kongo
wieder auferstehen und könnte wieder das
werden was er einmal war nämlich die
kornkammer zentralafrikas ich sage immer
der combo könnte auch bei geschlossenen
grenzen überleben denn hier gibt es
alles diese projekte lassen die schule
habe eine zukunft für das land glauben
ähnlich geht es ihren kindern trotz
alles schrecken
was mögen sie eigentlich an co alles was
zum beispiel zum beispiel die kultur und
die einfach eine tatsache dass es immer
die ärmsten sind die wir alles geben
es ist nicht wie in europa wo man in den
kleinen zellen lebt und kaum die
nachbarn kennt in kongo wirst du immer
freundlich empfangen
trotz allem was passiert ist was sind
ihre gefühle
ich spüre diese verbundenheit und gehe
darum mindestens
in den kongo und nach meinem studium
werde ich zurückkehren können sie sich
vorstellen dort zu leben und was werden
sie dort tun
ich habe bewusst eine breite fläche
auswahl studiert um mehrere
möglichkeiten zu haben
ich kann im management von hotels oder
restaurants arbeiten
ich habe auch noch marketing studiert
ich kann so auch in einer bank arbeiten
oder sonst wo ich habe fächer gewählt
die ich auch im kom gebrauchen kann das
mit divx teams mutter lebt unterstützen
die schule es nebst ihren anderen
aktivitäten auch eine schule
sie ließen alle schulhäuser neu bauen
vor allem mit geldern aus der schweiz
gespendet von vielen verwandten und
freunden im kanton uri
das ist nicht mehr als ein tropfen auf
einen heißen stein aber eine idee die
schüler sicher sind dass kein geld
verschwendet wird
die kinder des kunden
sie sollen es einmal besser haben
auch darum ist carlos hier gebieten in
der heimat seine frau gemeinsam werden
sie weiter kämpfen und sei es nur dafür
dass jedes kind jeden tag zur schule
gehen kann
es gibt noch hoffnung im herzen der
finsternis
[Applaus]
[Musik]